I feel good about my life and my
decision-making skills just cuz these
tights I've never won types of workout I
think the closest I've done was like a
mild amount of spandex for marathon
running yeah I've noticed some more guys
at the gym wearing them I don't know if
I am cool enough or have to get enough
body to pull it off you know I don't
wear tights right now because I think
it's just traditional masculine anything
if it's more comfortable and more
functional yeah why not all right yeah
I'm down to try these tights on tights
feel good I like them it actually feels
surprisingly good like if there's a wind
that goes by I really feel the game it's
like much cooler on my legs you feel
really nice it's really actually kind of
comfortable I just don't know how I feel
about showing on to the world so gonna
have a lot of movement and then I feel
mobile really shows off my gams all
right let's do this
I do kind of feel like a superhero in
this outfit sort of like the sixties
Batman with the flash every time I was
bending over doing that I've got a fresh
stream of air on the back I feel pretty
nice
I feel like this is like grabbing my ass
every time I go down it's like trying to
cop a feel
you know I'm liking it I feel loose but
I also feel supported if you know what I
mean
you know when I first took the tights on
I feel like I immediately was like I'm
okay with this at first I was
self-conscious but I really settled in
really quickly it felt great
everything's all nice and tucked away I
felt very agile it was almost like I was
working out in the nude I really get why
superheroes wear tights now we want to
show the bad guys with the working with
but also you want to feel good while
you're fighting crime if people really
want to try it out they should live life
with no inhibitions and yeah give tights
a try cuz they're wait tights on three
five eight one two three tights
[Music]